I've stood in the last five general
elections first time I embarrassed the
BNP in the last place second time
embarrassed the monster raving loon is
in last place third time I embarrass
myself into last pace last time I
embarrass the local vicar who went up
against me into last place you lost you
deposit four times yep that's two grand
yeah it's getting expensive hobby it's a
very expensive hobby what's with the the
garb then what's with the talk us
through that what the significance of
that means and the sword of truth it's
sort of a bit strange if you like
religious robes and politics but if you
actually look to the Far East the Middle
East and around the world it is not
without precedent you know a lot of
spiritual people who are also political
I mean famously over here of course we
had Reverend Ian Paisley you feel good
in this outfit do you feel different I
always feel different as soon as I robe
up yeah cuz yeah the elections not not
till my but you know more I get about
more people see me and more people talk
to me the more people get the message
your vote for me right yeah I was
reading it you the reincarnation of King
Arthur Sam say something but not how to
convince anybody that I'm the
reincarnation of King Arthur I'm just
saying we're up here now this is what
he'd be doing and what did we do any
stand if its roots honor and justice
you're gonna win I'm hoping to yeah
every other time I've just stood and
been a paper candidate I intend fight in
this one